[Música]
a
escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 si usted es estudiante investigador y
quiere ir a la región de parís a
estudiar hoy les vamos a dar todas las
claves con un estudiante en doctorado
colombiano que ha lanzado una plataforma
con todo lo que hay que saber sobre las
universidades y escuelas parisinas
andrés durán hernández muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros y sus
escritos y antes de entrar en materia y
de hablar de esa plataforma de ese sitio
web hablemos un poco de su trayectoria
estudio la secundaria en colombia llegó
a francia en 2014 donde obtuve una
licencia en matemáticas y física luego
se especializó en física fundamental y
ahora está haciendo el doctorado sobre
simulación cuántica en el college de
homes en el laboratorio kastler brossel
y hace un año lanza esta plataforma
ildefons academy para ayudar a los
estudiantes
y a los investigadores a situarse un
poco a los extranjeros que quieran venir
aquí a situarse un poco mejor en el
sistema educativo francés porque decide
lanzar este sitio web y cómo se le
ocurre esta idea bueno es una plataforma
fruto de un año de trabajo con dos
amigos míos denis y paul con quien
construimos si conseguimos
ildefons academy y es el producto de una
de nuestras experiencias personales y
sobre todo en el extranjero en el año
que empezamos a trabajar en el tema
yo estaba en roma' haciendo un año de
práctica
paul estaba en tokio y denis en
amsterdam y vimos de primera mano las
dificultades que tenían compañeros
nuestros del laboratorio para entender y
acceder a la información de los
laboratorios en francia de hecho una
anécdota es quién en en roma' una
compañera quería ser doctora otro parís
finalmente no pudo por razones obvias
sanitarias pero en un momento de buscar
física cuántica en parís
se encontró con una variedad tan grande
con una dificultad en la lengua en el
sistema en en tantas cosas que muchas
veces nos parecen como naturales que
quisimos
aplicar en explicar ya todo lo que
habíamos vivido todas las
digamos como las la forma como el
sistema funciona acá y volverlo
accesible a la gente en inglés por ahora
pero nos gustaría también tener en otras
lenguas
para fomentar la avenida de estudiantes
extranjeros
y justamente cuáles son las dificultades
con las que se encuentra un estudiante
extranjero si quiere venir a parís a
estudiar bueno como lo venía diciendo la
diversidad en los sistemas porque están
las universidades las escuelas desde
grandes escuelas etcétera hace que las
personas que nos están acostumbradas o
que no conocen
estos sistemas de educación paralelos la
investigación no saben dónde buscar
entonces vamos a decir que el primer
obstáculo pues es un tema de acceso a la
información por más de que haya
esfuerzos institucionales con
instituciones como campus house que
tratan también de ayudarle a los
estudiantes
por un lado está
el tema de los
también puede ser un tema de lengua
muchas veces tenemos laboratorios
universidades en las cuales la página
web no está actualizada o no está en
inglés o en español y para las personas
que todavía no manejan bien el francés
después del complicado
justamente el francés puede ser un
obstáculo en el inglés bueno más o menos
a nivel mundial es todo el mundo lo
estudian como segunda lengua si no es la
primera pero el francés no tanto el
francés es un obstáculo real puede ser
un obstáculo pienso que cada vez más las
universidades están abriendo formaciones
en inglés de hecho la formación que yo
tuve este año fue en inglés y está
abierta a estudiantes internacionales
pero todavía hay un largo camino por
recorrer antes de decir que el francés
no es un obstáculo y la mujer hay gente
que ni sabe que la formación puede ser
inglés en inglés no hace actualmente
uno de
otros problemas no es tal vez el tema de
la financiación parece ser una de las
ciudades más caras del mundo y además ha
habido recientemente hace un par de años
un cambio muy polémico impulsado por el
ministerio de educación francés que es
las tarifas de matrículas para los
extranjeros no comunitarios europeos han
subido y han subido muchísimo por
ejemplo dos mil setecientos setenta
euros para un año de licencia cuando
para los franceses o los comunitarios
europeos es de 170 euros por año y en el
caso del máster tres mil setecientos
setenta euros cuando para los franceses
o comunitarios europeos están solo de
243 cree que están medidas
discriminatorias
bueno es una medida que me sorprendió
muchísimo
sobre todo porque mis convicciones
personales
respecto a la educación es la
universalidad del acceso a la educación
y precisamente tener que subir de forma
diferenciada a los costos de acceso a
las formaciones en francia pienso que es
un error porque justamente en francia
hace alarde de esa de ese universalismo
no sé en qué opciones hay para
financiarse hay becas por ejemplo ayudas
si hay unas becas del gobierno francés
por medio con pistons para los
estudiantes que acaban de terminar el
colegio que salen del izado francés que
se llama la box exitoso y hay otras
becas para estudiantes para hacer
maestrías o doctorados en francia-
hacemos las becas eiffel también hay
otros tipos de financiación en fondos
privados sobre los gobiernos locales
pero esas son las que se me vienen a la
cabeza después de estados unidos y reino
unido francia es el país que acoge a más
estudiantes extranjeros cada año a
310.000 y eso que sus universidades
tampoco están entre las mejores del
mundo como explica este éxito de las
universidades en francia
la educación en francia- universidad en
francés tiene trayectoria histórica
queda reconocida mundialmente y pienso
que es uno de los principales atractivos
también
la variedad de las formaciones y la
excelencia que puede haber por ejemplo
en el tema científico en el ámbito
científico
en las matemáticas también parís es la
ciudad tengo entendido con más
matemáticos con metros cuadrados del
mundo
explican que sea un pueblo atractivo y
un polo de investigación y educación
también artístico cultural
bueno y uno de los objetivos que se ha
marcado es que aún sea más atractiva
esta ciudad parís
y es que hayan más científicos
latinoamericanos en los laboratorios de
investigación parisinos usted que
diagnóstico hace de esa escena
científica y creo que paris es atractivo
como
destino para estudiar en materia
científica pienso que podría ser más
atractivo en experiencia personal me
encontraba muy pocos latinoamericanos
estudiando física o matemáticas a lo
largo la carrera de estos 7 años sé
quién en francia
pienso que deberíamos en francia- arias
en un mayor esfuerzo para seducir al
público latinoamericano que también
tiene mucho potencial y que también
podría aprovechar y contribuir el
desarrollo sin carrera donde el suelo
natural sea más eeuu no acerca también
bueno y para eso está participando en un
canal
de divulgación científica
explíquenos cómo se llama y qué hace ahí
bueno desde este año estoy contribuyendo
un canal que se llama saints clic en la
versión en español sainz clic en español
que fundó un compañero mío de pregrado
en de física y matemáticas
la idea es explicar visualmente
fenómenos físicos y volverlos accesibles
a la gente que no necesariamente hizo
estudios o que todavía no sabe si quiere
hacer estudios científicos luego lo que
yo estoy haciendo es traducir y narrar
los vídeos que ya fueron hechos por un
amigo
precisamente para el público
latinoamericano es por hablar de la
formación universitaria se ha visto muy
perturbada en los últimos meses por la
pandemia de coronavirus por las
restricciones el cierre de universidades
y hemos visto bueno colas inmensas de
estudiantes para ir a buscar comida
porque muchos estudiantes aparte de
estudiar tienen que trabajar unas horas
a la semana para poder
financiarse
como han sufrido los estudiantes
latinoamericanos esta pandemia este
parón en parís bueno hay dos tipos vamos
a decir dos formas diferentes de vivir
como la pandemia ha afectado a los
estudiantes ha probado las las personas
que trabajaban para poder financiar los
estudios en restaurantes o cuidando
niños soltando clases si vivieron sin
esa fuente ingreso y por otros los que
tenían una financiación de sus padres o
familiares o local vieron los costos
aumentar precisamente por la situación
económica en los países por ejemplo en
vía desarrollo los países
latinoamericanos en la cual por
inflación el precio del euro sube
entonces
los estudios se vuelven más costoso
licitación complicada no sí y no sólo
eso también el aislamiento
por estar pues por tener el atlántico
entre claros disposición a un estudiante
italiano igual era más fácil volver
desde francia italia que que a
latinoamérica por las restricciones
efectivamente yo le quería preguntar si
se están normalizando la situación los
estudiantes extranjeros pueden empezar a
venir a parís pero hace falta un pase
sanitario y francia nos reconoce todas
las vacunas por ejemplo la china no la
reconoce en latinoamérica
ha habido muchas vacunas con la china
con sinovac para usted se está
normalizando la situación
aún falta un poco de tiempo para hablar
de eso yo quiero creer que si se está
normalizando
y bueno para las personas que no quieren
venir y que todavía no han podido tener
el esquema de vacuna reconocido por las
autoridades sanitarias francesas francia
está vacunando a los
estudiantes e investigadores extranjeros
que quieren venir a ejercer acá a esto
es muy interesante o sea si no han
tenido la vacuna y como ocurre esto a
través de las embajadas o de los
consulados en los países
latinoamericanos
bueno una vez que la persona que tenga
este aceptada en la universidad obtenga
el trabajo aquí digamos que llegar al
proyecto esté en marcha sin en forma
tiene la va con el país de origen
algunas condiciones para entrar en el
país con una especie de re menos de 48
horas o 72 en función de los país del
país del que venga y todo se maneja con
un campus host una vez que la persona
tenga aquí el número seguridad social
puede haber alguna moría antes de
despedirnos andrés querría que nos diera
un par de consejos para los estudiantes
extranjeros que quieran ir a parís a
estudiar mi consejo el consejo más
importante diría que es atreverse a
tocar puertas a insistir soñar y no
dejarse vencer por los obstáculos que
puede tener la travesía dice el país de
origen
a formarse y crear cosas nuevas
aquí en francia week in paris sobre todo
consultar esta plataforma
antes de venir ildefons academy que es
bueno ile-de-france guión medio academia
en inglés junto con muchísimas gracias
andrés durán hernández por esta
entrevista y le deseamos muchísimos
éxitos con esta plataforma y en su
carrera también muchísimas gracias
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf
elmundo.com france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]